this was a big year for the tea party in
a lot of scary ways i think this sort of
it culminated the highlight for them i
think was the ted cruz filibuster right
before the government shutdown and if
you forgot it well dr. seuss the
difference with green eggs and ham is
when Americans tried it they discovered
they did not like green eggs and ham and
they did not like Obamacare either they
did not like Obamacare in a box with a
fox in a house or with the mouse people
are frustrated because their elected
officials don't listen Gary we are we
are subjected to a tremendous amount of
idiocy out of Washington mostly out of
Congress was that v stupidest moment I
mean was that just the dumbest we had
the biggest lie before the clapper but
was that type of thing and then what
then led to the shutdown was that our
dummy political moment [ __ ] because he's
like an American people tried it and
then like it didn't try Obamacare it
doesn't affect in the 2014 right um you
know the way I wasn't even not working
yeah that's right the website has had
yet to fail and crash right and if
they're already bashing it so look I
mean the proper Ted Cruz that he's
actually I could see why he's appealing
because he says just enough truth and
that's what he's more so much more
dangerous because he does tap into that
frustration that people feel with their
government but he's not the guy doesn't
bring about the change that they really
want because we all feel that the the
fact is our representatives they don't
represent us they represent the moneyed
interests so Cruz purports to be the guy
who will bypass the money and interest
and he will support us like that the
actual people but it's just not true and
he at best at best he will represent
that in the fringed the extreme fringe
yeah because the reality is that when
government works and it when it works
well it does great things for society
and you know it's like having a freeway
system so having having the parks is
having an army is having a ETA yeah is
having the FDA so you don't die from
eating poor
is having a clean environment I mean
we'd have cops yes fireman yeah
regulators uh yes become enforcing the
rules so that we all said we're all
better off we can't have anarchy
obviously and you know Ted Cruz taps
into that because every because we all
get fresh about a government you know
what is a parking ticket or your PIN
your taxes we get frustrated he taps
into that very effectively yeah well he
does that really well and there's
something interesting about somebody
that in a weird way the far left and the
far right should all be agreeing on
certain things about money basically but
he's tapping into a whole other paranoid
delusion thing was this a good year bad
year for the for the tea party I think
it was ultimately a bad year for the Tea
Party I think that well it's the
interesting thing because Ted Cruz says
not popular that people don't like
Obamacare people tried it they don't
like it they rejected well let me tell
you something Ted Cruz Ted Cruz's
approval ratings in America or fourteen
percent Obamacare's approval rating is
forty-six percent okay so it's it's a by
a factor of I don't know three it's more
popular than you are Obamacare and that
poll about Obamacare was taken at its
lowest point in the rollout so when the
big Fiasco was happening they took that
and people still liked at forty-six
percent let me tell you something else
when you take individual parts of
Obamacare and you ask Republicans how
they feel about it overwhelmingly they
like most of Obamacare except for the
individual mandate but if they were told
where that came from they switch so
that's the above the amazing thing about
Ted Cruz and we he's it up steve is
right he's appealing because he taps
into our frustration with government but
that he doesn't give you a real solution
what he does is [ __ ] you nothing he just
goes Obamacare is [ __ ] up so I'm gonna
give you nothing to replace it I got the
best health care plan in the world I got
mine screw you that's Ted Cruz ball to
literally give an example of we're
saying the government shutdown cost how
much 24 billion dollars I think and it
did not accomplish anything I think not
not a thing um should we on the Left
have a tea party do you think that the
Democrats actually need a TV re to push
or
to pull more left well I like to UM
Howard Dean when he was running for
president in 2008 and he kept saying I'm
from the Democratic wing of the
Democratic Party and of course they had
to shut him down right away because he
was speaking with people really wanted
to hear so I think definitely we need
more Howard ease within Howard Dean then
got co-opted you know because his party
won so now he's a good Democrat so he
shuts the [ __ ] up you know the head of
the end they make him the head sir they
give them this big prize at the end so
uh what do they do do we need the
progressives need a political movement
like they have the tea party yes
absolutely and I think most Americans
would be on their side yes I mean if you
poll Americans on any issue they pull
way way progressive up in overwhelming
majorities it's just that we don't have
representatives who actually represent
those interests because I represent the
interests of the moneyed interests right
so so yes if we had if we had people
like you know there's their few like
alan grayson is a good guy Bernie
Sanders there there are a few who are
terrific and their problem is that they
just don't get the fair treatment from
the media the media to seem like they're
crazy people all the extreme left all
they want things like you know clean air
and water and standards so the oil
companies just can't rape our natural
resources they're crazy like that they
don't want to cut security medicare
steve they want to cut Social Security
American two things that don't add to
our deficit that aren't a problem yeah
um so do they need like a celebrity then
basically cuz yeah there are people i
mean Vern centers obviously too old to
really becomes you know he doesn't want
anything bigger than what he's got or
somebody like Grayson is just sort of
back in it again but is there some is it
going to be Matt Damon there's nobody
like would it take somebody like that to
really build a party it would be nice to
see a Progressive Caucus actually speak
with the unified voice and you know
there are enough for you know those Ron
Wyden there's a senator Brown there's
Bernie Sanders and yes if they would
just come together all keep constantly
you know that's the beauty of the right
wing is that you know George Bush even
he said it a whole
Oh deve he said you know it's a its
governing is all just about launching
propaganda you just have to keep
launching it and launching it until it
sets in and that's what the Democrats
don't do they don't have a message they
don't have a central message and i think
the progressives need to pick up the
ball and have a message in you know you
talk about the Tea Party I think we're
the Tea Party of the Democrats you know
that wolf pack and the young turks and
people like us are but we need to
somehow influence real leadership you
know I mean we need to get them to be
more responsive to us because the
government is a responsive I mean if you
look at the day the perfect example of
that from this last year's we're talking
about year and is that the gun bill
which had ninety percent support in the
public of course it didn't pass because
what steve says it the moneyed interest
didn't want it to pass yeah yeah look I
don't have time but just real this real
quick thing I mean you know look our
taxes i mean taxing is one of the
biggest part of what government does the
Progressive Caucus proposed a
progressive budget and what they would
do is they would tax us at I graduated
rapes going all the way up from you know
from nothing to you know I think billion
dollars so right now the tax rates don't
make any sense because for example if
you make above above two and fifty
thousand dollars you pay the same rate
as a as a multi-billionaire yeah why
right okay obviously from 50,000 to two
and fifty thousand that's a big gap but
from 200,000 to to 220 220 million 225
billion is a much bigger gap you should
have it should be graduated so so let's
say the top marginal rate is
thirty-three percent whatever it may be
if you make above a million dollars you
should be maybe thirty six percent above
10 million dollars maybe thirty eight
percent above a billion dollars maybe
forty two percent even for ya coopers
and if we did that you know we know what
happened it would wipe out the deficit
we can fund education we could fund you
know alternative energy we could just so
much yeah and why would the
conservatives and end up and the Tea
Party not being favored this because its
own it's the most fair way of doing a
stealing money from the producers the
people who are the job creators you're
stealing money
them to give to people who are lazy
that's what they would say in I'll tell
you this about Teddy say let's raise the
income tax so billionaire but
billionaires don't pay income tax Mitt
Romney prove that so what what they so
that what they do is they pay fifteen
percent investment tax right so they pay
capital gains taxes so we need to get
capital gains back up to where yeah but
the idea behind capital gains is if we
lower the amount of money we tax when
someone invest in a business then people
will invest more the problem is people
are still gonna invest no matter how
much attacks them cuz people want to
make [ __ ] money I'll make seventy
gonna make seventy percent return or
sixty percent return I'll take both
whichever one I can get I'll take fifty
percent return I'll take it twenty
percent if I can invest money and make
money back that's what we're talking
about savings accounts let's remember
pay nothing anymore so nobody talks
about that not being an incentive to say
would you say only save if i get
seventy-five percent thirty percent on
mcafee but that doesn't this go to the
messaging problem because as the one
percent we all talk about the one
percent and it's a great number it's
like if you like a plan keep it's just
that simple thing but really the one
percent we did a thing on a couple weeks
ago it's something like 250 thousand
dollars you're the one percent but you
can have two hundred thousand dollars
and really not be rolling in a ton you
know and then living a nice decent
middle-upper class life but so it's not
about that we should have a progressive
tax that really when you're talking
about millions of dollars and hundreds
of dollars and ultimately the billions
of dollars so that the walmart family
doesn't own as much as the bottom for
the estate tax used to take care of all
that at the end so and when you died
right okay you got to have all your
money for your whole life and then when
you died we took half your money and
then cuz you know you got to benefit
from living in this country and the
society that we built now we you have to
pay for it after you're dead but then
they stopped doing that because they had
around five million hours they had a
vote to see who had to pay taxes dead
people dead millionaires or living
people and gets the one [ __ ] dead
millionaires that's how powerful money
is well that's good yeah it's true and
it's ridiculous because it's not really
the top 1% that's a problem is a top
point we per se yeah because if you're
the top 1% your
so much pretty much aligned with most
people in the ninety eight percent
because my analogy is this if you're if
you're making two hundred thousand
dollars a year that you're not that
means that means you can afford to eat a
nice steak making fifty thousand a year
you eat a burger okay if we're making
less it did maybe get a hot dog whatever
maybe but if you're making 20 million a
year you own the whole restaurant and
the entire city block okay so is that
it's a game changers is a totally
different level when you're making
millions and millions of dollars I mean
this two fifties I mean it's a Hunger
Games is it's like that the Stuber rich
making it people who make 250 thousand
dollars 50 the people who make fifty
thousand dollars okay that that's a
silly fight right it's the wrong fight
but on that note hot dogs on me after
the gym and I got a lot can I give you a
final thought on us and uh before
nineteen eighty the upper five percent
had accumulated 40 trillion dollars
which is a lot of money 40 trillion
dollars sense then the upper five
percent have accumulated more money than
the entire human race had produced prior
to nineteen eighty think about that's
that that's a big stat and that comes
from david stockman ronald reagan's
budget director right so a segment on
tea party basically we ended with
progressive tax look it up